hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
solving confusion with regulations qc
design and troubleshooting for sars cov2
assays
i am jen woods of labrutz and i will be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labries and sponsored
by
technopath clinical diagnostics usa
for more information about our sponsor
please visit their site
at technopathclinicaldiagnostics.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far
left of your screen i'd like to now
introduce our presenters
stan westgard director of client
services and technology
westgard quality control and sharon dr
sharon hermeyer professor emeritus
pathology
and laboratory medicine university of
wisconsin-madison
for a complete biography on our
presenters please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen
dr ermeyer you may now begin your
presentation
well thank you jen i am sharon hermeyer
and today we're going to be talking
about
uh the corona virus and
this uh
slide shows uh of course the virus that
we've
become very familiar with and then where
we
were on december 4th
uh 2020 and
uh we can see that
at that time there were 67 million
global cases and 1.5
million deaths it is really
something and i can just imagine what it
is
today it just grows and grows
unbelievably fast
now we're going to be talking a lot
about
emergency use authorization these
eua tests and
i find this to be very confusing so i
thought
i would look uh eua up and see
what would come up and
the definition states that in
emergencies
certainly which covet is an emergency
and when no products are available on
the market
the eua legally permits
the fda to
authorize unapproved medical products
and so this is a whole bunch of things
to diagnose treat prevent
serious or life-threatening diseases
conditions
caused by chemical biological
radiological and or nuclear
events so that's what the eu a
is all about it it's a way to get them
out from the manufacturer
onto the market
and then if we look at eua testing for
the laboratory
oh my gosh it's just absolutely
overwhelming there are so many tests
and i stopped at the end of october
and uh what i have up here on the screen
just shows some 300 tests
to choose from and again if you were to
go to that today
the website that i have i'm sure
you know there will be more so i really
feel for
test sites uh on selecting
the appropriate test for their situation
now what do we do in terms of testing
and i can't emphasize this
enough really you always have to check
with cms the centers for medicare and
medicaid services which really
you know this is where we get the clia
regulations
from and remember that clia sets the
minimum
certainly if you are accredited by say
the joint commission or cola or the
college of american pathology
they can do and require more
but you need to follow what is
appropriate for you and again this is
just like the testing there's so much
information out there
that it's very easy to get lost
in information so
what i have done today or what i have
done
for today is to prepare
some charts so if you look at this
chart here on the left
the the leftmost column i have
the testing requirement so for instance
in the first
row it states it's a clear certificate
allowing wave testing if you need one
that's the the
question actually and for clea it says
yes
for cola accreditation yes and the same
is true
for the joint commission and cap
so that's just the beginning i have
several of these
charts and i have done a series for wave
testing and you know this is
probably the largest category of testing
out there and i have included the
requirements
for clea cola the joint commission
and the college of american pathology
so let's uh go ahead and look at
some of these in more detail
so the first red circle here
the requirement is specific testing
requirements for
wave test methods now
just like in any other wave test method
under clia there are really
no requirements other than to follow the
manufacturer's directions
and that's absolutely true for
the emergency utilization
authorized tests as well
for cola yes you have to
follow the manufacturer's directions
that's always the cardinal rule
in testing but then you also need to
follow the
applicable wave standards in their
current accreditation manual so if you
are cola accredited you certainly have
access to their manual and you can just
go to that section and follow those
requirements
as well as for the joint commission
again you need to follow the
manufacturers requirements
but this time you follow the wave
testing standards
in there meaning the joint commission's
current
comprehensive laboratory accreditation
manual for
laboratory and point of care
and then lastly the same thing is true
for cap but now you need to follow the
applicable standards in their current
checklist and again if you're cap
accredited you're
really familiar with those checklists
and
uh the ones that i have specified here
are the
uh general the all common and the point
of
care so going on
uh what about quality control now we're
still in the wave testing category
and uh for
gma cms who again
is responsible for the clio regulations
you have to follow manufacturers
directions and if we look at cola
the joint commission and cap
all of them say yes you have to follow
the manufacturer's directions for
quality control
and you have to perform this quality
control at
least at the frequency of the
manufacturer's directions
now what they're really saying is you
may decide to do
more and that's fine but the minimum
is the manufacturer's directions
and if you look just at the bottom
of that red circle the requirement
is to develop and follow site-specific
iqcps and that's an individualized
quality control plan that i know that
many of you are
very familiar with but for wave
testing no there is no
requirement for iqcp because
it's very clearly stated you need
to follow the manufacturer's directions
and so you can't reduce that at all
with an iq cp
so this is uh i've been following
the common questions uh that come in
on various frequently asked questions
and answers
for all of the organizations and i think
that
again since cms is the
bottom line developer for qc and iqcp
it's good to see what they say so the
question is can a lab develop an
individualized quality control plan
and cms says that manufactures
quality control instructions for all
eua testing must be followed
and this includes qc
and it goes on and says because qc for
these eua tests must be
followed and no deviations to the qc
requirements are permitted then an
iqcp is not applicable
for this type of testing
now note that the laboratory director
may determine based on risk
assessments and that's a big part of
iqcp development
that additional qc needs to be
implemented
above what is required in the
instructions
but never less
and then going on with the requirements
for wave testing what i have circled
here
is mandated personnel training and
competency assessments
and certainly these activities would be
documented well just as we would expect
for clia this is not a requirement
because it's not a requirement
in any wave testing but i think
that those of us in the testing business
for any period of time we realize
that it may not be an actual requirement
if you're
being uh inspected by
clia or and not going with a
professional organization we realize
that it may not be required but it
certainly is essential as part of
good testing practices for quality test
results cola
joint commission and cap
all training and competency assessment
and they really uh
follow the same requirements as
they uh require for any
other wave testing this would be non-eua
requirements
so just to reiterate this
clea there's none but
you better do some and for
the three organizations that i have
listed here
all require training and competency
assessments and you would
do what's in your accrediting
manual
okay what about this training and i just
want to give an example this comes out
of the joint commission
so this is really only relevant to
those who are accredited by the joint
commission
and it's listing here
some requirements for staff performing
wave testing and so you know it really
shows
that the difference here from
accrediting organizations
putting on more demands to the testing
process
compared to clia which has
no requirements
many good things listed here
and the other organizations have good
things as
well okay
we're still continuing with the wave
testing for the eua
requirements and uh the question here
the requirement here really is are there
policies and procedures to train
personnel collecting the patient
sample including training
now remember in some cases
depending upon the test actually being
used
the collection can be quite unique and
so
do these people doing just the
collecting
not the testing necessarily but for the
collecting
aspect is are their requirements
and cms as you might guess
does not mandate anything but again i'm
saying it's really essential
for quality test results because our
results are only as good
as the specimen we receive
cola has requirements for people
collecting the specimen
commission has requirements and
cap has requirements as
well the next requirement
method performance specifications
that means do we have to verify or
validate the test
before we put it into use
now remember these are wave tests and so
again
cms says no not a requirement
but of course it doesn't require this
for any of the wave testing that is done
in the laboratory
where cola joint commission
and cap have
some minimum requirements and really
what they say and i think coal is a good
example here
yes to the extent required by the
manufacturer
and or organization and when we're
talking really about the organization
you know the director is always in
charge and so it would be up to the
director then to decide
uh if performance specifications need to
be checked
now looking at the second circle
this is about
reporting the results and it doesn't
matter what the results are they could
be the molecular results it could be
anagen it could be antibody
the uh idea is if something is
run and the result is intended to detect
sars cov2
or diagnose covet 19
then it has to be reported to the
appropriate
health authorities and that typically
is in the state that you live in but
make sure
that you find out specifically
where these results have to be reported
and if you've been following this
requirement at all
you'll realize that there's a lot to be
reported and i can tell you that
it seems like many testing sites have
really been
blocking that all of the things that
have to be
required or have to be included within
this reported result
so make sure to find out about that for
your particular
situation now
i don't in the previous slide and i can
go back there
notice under clea i have down here
item 493.41 of the regulations
and i thought well you know i really
better look that up to see what's going
on
and this has just been inserted
this is why it's really important you
have to go to the website
that i have uh listed on the bottom
there that really
long ridiculous website and what they do
is that they do up grade
um the
clia regulations on a regular basis and
i just did this a couple of days ago
and it says very specifically you know
that it wasn't there originally because
it
cites the public health emergency
each laboratory that performs a test
that is intended to detect
or diagnose a possible case must
report the test results to the secretary
in such a form and manner and at this
such time and frequency as the secretary
may prescribe so
you need to look into the public health
department
in your state to see how to go about
doing this properly
okay now we are going over
to non-waived testing
so the wave testing done at point of
care
uh very popular in terms of the
choices for the number of upward testing
that can be selected for testing at
point of care
non-waived there are some
more i don't want to say own a risk
because that's not the case but
more requirements applicable to non-wave
testing just
as with all the other testing that we do
in the laboratory
so um the first thing that falls under
this red
circle it is asking about
follow requirements for specific clia
testing specialty and subspecialty
and remember that when you look at the
clear requirements there are some
general requirements but then there are
specialty requirements
for example chemistry and hematology but
then we also get into the infectious
diseases
but in truth here there are no special
requirements here
because these tests have not
been assigned a clia specialty and
subspecialty
area so there's nothing that we can
follow
or no place that we can be directed to
for the regulations
and you'll notice that that's what clea
says and then of course
cola joint commission and cap follow
going on to quality control daily
quality control
still the cardinal rule about following
the manufacturer's directions
and just like in wave testing
you have to do at a minimum following
the manufacturer's directions but
cola joint commission and cap says hey
listen you have to do that but you can
do
more well then the next requirement gets
back
into developing and following
site-specific
iqcps and that would be the thing again
that the site would decide whether they
wanted to develop an iqcp
i read you back several slides ago that
cms
said no not necessary you have to follow
the manufacturer's directions
but interestingly all three accrediting
organizations
do allow iqcps
that go beyond following the
manufacturer's directions
but this becomes very confusing
and if you want to develop an iqcp
because remember
normally we develop an iqcp
to reduce the amount of qc
we don't want to do qc daily when we
follow an iqcp
so all i can say is no for cms
if you want to develop an iqcp and
you're accredited by cola the joint
commissioner cap
to make sure to contact
them to see if this is really the right
thing
to do
now moving on and we're still looking at
the non-wave testing
we talked about performance
specifications for wave do we have to
verify or validate them and
and the answer for waived is generally
no but we can we're here now we're in
the non-wave category
and cms says
yes you need to do this and you need to
follow all the applicable clea
requirements that are that you normally
would do
for all the other non-wave testing
performed in your laboratory
and the same is true for cola
joint commission and cap and they all
have
their own requirements to do that
and then this last circle here
this is asking about proficiency testing
in a cms approved
regulatory pt program
and cms says no
these eua tests are not assigned a
specialty or subspecialty
so therefore they're not included in
regulatory
pt but they
you know just in other cases of testing
if we're not in pt then we perform
some alternative accuracy assessments
for those tests
not in regulatory pt
now for cola joint commission
and cap it's really
the same requirements as clea
but again you follow your accrediting
agency's
appropriate requirements and they
all state that if you're not in
regulatory pt because there really
are none then you need to perform
alternate accuracy assessment
and for instance we know that cap has
some proficiency testing samples out
there
in my state wisconsin they run a
proficiency testing program and they
also have
proficiency testing samples and you can
use the data
from analyzing this type
of sample to assess
accuracy
now
i want to look one more time at
competency
assessment we looked at training and
certainly
for non-waived testing everybody doing
the testing
has to be trained prior to doing the
test
and they also have to have their
competency
assessed on a regular basis
and cms is
very specific and all of the other
organizations
follow what is required
for competency assessment so i have
listed
the six things that need to be
accomplished
on this particular slide and so it's no
different than
any other testing you just do the same
for eua testing
well what about when this is over and
boy i'm sure for all of us it can't be
over
fast enough just a reminder that
when eua ends i'm assuming when the
pandemic is under control
these tests that are out there will need
to go
through the regular fda
approval so regulatory life
will return to pre-eua
times and all clear cola and the joint
commission and cap
regular regulatory testing requirements
that we use for everything else in the
laboratory
will apply to these tests
as well so
when it's over it's over and for me it
can't be over
soon enough here are some references for
you there's
so much information out there that i
really cannot stress enough
that always check with the organization
that you use for the regulations
these people really do want to help you
succeed so
with this i want to thank you for your
attention
and now i'm going to turn it over to
stan westgard
for his presentation thank you
thank you sharon for that wonderful
presentation
uh we really get a good idea of
how the regulatory landscape has shifted
during this time of emergency and
clearly the regulators
have had to make changes to adapt to
the eua era it will be interesting to
see what happens when
we go away from emergency use
but in the same sense we have to think
about what is happening
to quality control what happens to
quality control
when there is an emergency
now i'm just gonna
back up a little bit and introduce
myself
this is something i have to do on a lot
of webinars
uh when you hear my voice you might be
expecting another west guard that would
be
james o westgard the father not only of
the westgard rules but also
my father and while he has been working
in laboratory medicine
for 50 years i am the junior employee
i have only been doing this for a little
over
25 years a lot of what we've done during
the
pandemic era has been about
trying to inform as many people as
possible about
qualifying and selecting the best
quality methods
and we put more than a dozen articles up
on
our websites our our most
popular website is westgard.com more
than 68 000 laboratory professional
members
more than a million views on the on the
home page
every month more than 600 articles on
non-coded topics but
more than a dozen directly related to
sars kobe 2 testing
one thing that sharon noted earlier
was uh how many tests had come
onto the market so fast in order to
address the the dire urgent need
for diagnosing and characterizing
infections but qc has sort of followed
behind it's lagged behind the
introduction of these methods
and so qc has been not really spoken of
what is emergency use qc well
no one has really defined it
one of the goals that i'm going to have
for
this part of the presentation is to try
to try and bring the bear
some sanity to how we're going to do qc
in our emergency use era and once we
return to
regular use and we're going to walk
through a couple examples
of qc failures that we've come across
with
different sars kobe 2 tests and we'll
even provide
a few troubleshooting tips
the thing i want to emphasize most is
in a time of emergency quality
is not something you put in the back
seat
when you look at these two vehicles do
you decide
only one of them requires seat belts
when there's an emergency and you're in
an ambulance do you decide
i don't need safety features in my
vehicles i don't need airbags i don't
need
seat belts it's an emergency i just need
to get
somewhere fast actually it's
it's almost the opposite when you're in
an emergency that's when you need
quality the most
when we have these diagnoses with such
tremendous consequences for the patient
we need to be as accurate as possible
this is the time when qc is actually
more important
not less
and one of the the downsides of having
so many methods come to market
so quickly is that many of them are not
of sufficient quality
there's a lot of evidence to the
contrary that all
stars kobe 2 methods are far from
perfect
just a couple days ago the wh show
in their database listed almost a
thousand methods
for sars kobe 2 and this is pcr
and antibody and antigen within the us
the fda has
only approved 227
molecular methods 61 antibody
methods and seven antigen methods
far less than 1000 and in fact
there are 181 antibody lists
on the do not distribute list
of the fda that is for every one method
that the fda will give the emergency use
authorization it is denying
three methods that same emergency use
so that's saying 75 of the methods on
the market
may not be good enough that's a very
chilling idea and it should
it it should give you a pause
you should think when i select a method
i better be
extra selective because there's a lot
out there
that may be offered to you for cheap
or for convenience but in fact
these are bad methods and they are not
going to serve your patients well
when we come to doing qc on sars
kobe 2 methods we face the same
options that we would with any other
method
we could use a manufacturer or package
insert ranges
we could use full west guard rules
or we could do something in the middle
now the use of package insert ranges
on there's a long history of of knowing
those ranges are too big
they're probably too wide they'll be
insensitive
they won't pick up errors but they do
serve a purpose
and that is when you're just starting
out
if you have no other information about
the performance of the method
you use that package insert information
first
and then once you get 20 data points
once you get a month of information
on performance you quickly switch to
that
another tradition in a lot of testing is
throw all the westgard rules at a test
and some some labs will throw westgard
rules at everything
that might have been good in 1981 when
the westgard rules were
first introduced but today
um if we have selected a method with
good performance
full westgard rules may in fact be too
strict
it may cause us to define
some things as out of control or reject
runs
when actually the problems we're
detecting have no clinical
importance
what we would like to do is find out a
way
to choose just enough westgard rules
as the method requires if we don't know
the performance of the method
however if we have no characterization
we don't know if it's
a high quality method or a low quality
method
in the absence of that performance
understanding
using full westgard rules may be of
maybe a useful resort
if you don't know anything yes go ahead
and use the westgard rules but hopefully
after some weeks of operating the method
you will gain a better understanding and
be able to customize and tailor your use
of qc rules
and what we'd like is that this middle
ground of
the use of westgard rules we
these days on on methods outside of sars
kobe 2 testing
there's a strong uh practice
of characterizing the method on the six
sigma scale
and then using that sigma metric to
drive
not only the rules to use but even the
number of controls to run
and the qc frequency
let's take a moment to understand how
antibiotic testing for sars kobe 2 is
similar to all the other tests that we
have in our laboratory
first we do have a continuous
measurement signal
even though the final result may be
classified as negative or positive
under the hood there are numbers
and we can with controls determine the
variation
of the measurement process
while in the very beginning of this
panda pandemic we did not have
commercial controls now they are
available the
control vendors have caught up you can
run a third party control on a method
those controls will have a normal
distribution and therefore
all the principles of statistical qc
apply but let's also acknowledge
how sars kobe 2 methods are different
for antibody testing of course we have
cutoff values
and that will that's what we get
that can cause us to have false
positives and false negative values
so that those areas are not the same as
our continuously
variable numbers that we would
report to a clinician another challenge
is that
in this vacuum of methods
we in uh nearly a thousand new methods
rushed in
and many methods lack
primary standards or reference methods
against which they can compare
so that means certain you know values
for method to method
may not be comparable
another issue is the use of arbitrary
units
so depending on how the signal to cut
off ratio
is created the manufacturer may say
x is a low positive but that same number
on a signal-to-cutoff ratio on another
manufacturer might be considered
a straight positive so that makes it
even more difficult to compare methods
and of course there are no standards for
normal biologic variation
because a virus is not normally
in humans we don't have a natural
occurring
biologic variation and then you can't
derive
from biologic variation
a specification for quality or an
allowable total error
here we start our look at
real world problems being found
in laboratories running cyrus kobe 2
methods
and here you see it's the same
instrument same method
but two sets of controls
the top control or control a
you can see the variation is minimal
there are no outliers according to
control
a the method is fine and steady and
the laboratory is happy but if you look
at control
d you can see there is a persistent
systemic decline there's a systematic
error that's
impacting the method
across the whole time period in which
these controls have been run
but do you want to guess which control
is supplied by the manufacturer
and which one is the third party
independent control
it's probably not hard to guess that
control a
was provided by the manufacturer control
a was probably
created with quite a bit of
uh optimization for a particular reagent
law
and therefore it's not giving a real
view of instrument performance it's
giving an idealized one
and that control provided by the
manufacturer
also gives the manufacturer fewer
technical support calls
on the other hand control b is the third
party control
it provides an independent look and it
has caught
a systematic decline in the values
this is why iso 15189 strongly
recommends
that laboratories run third party qc
and in a time where not only are the
methods being rushed to market
the reagents are being rushed through
production
so we have reagent issues that are
coming on top of method problems
and we need controls to be able to
detect
these problems because otherwise if we
see those declines
and they are actually impacting patients
we start getting misdiagnoses
and that's and we're already facing so
many other problems
with sars kobe 2 testing we don't want
to increase the number of
false positives or false negatives that
are going out the door
here's another example this is a reagent
shift
that has been caught by a third party
control and you can see that is a major
reagent shift that is a pretty big
jump in values
this is why a third-party control
is so important
as i said earlier we have known this
this is not
news that third-party controls pick up
errors that manufacturer controls
don't just a recent article
by dr pat garrett you can find it
you can see the link this is mlo online
and this is picking up
happens not to be a sars kobe 2
method but it's another infectious
disease method
and it's related and here
the independent control picks up a
significant change
in performance while a manufacturer's
control
did not
so we acknowledge that the independent
controls will help us pick up
errors better faster
but what happens once we've picked up
that error
how do we actually troubleshoot the
method
are there special ways that cyrus cov2
methods must be troubleshooted
or is troubleshooting agnostic about
what the test is troubleshooting
your troubleshooting protocol can be
customized to a method
but there are some things that are
universal to all methods in trouble
and one of those is that there are two
kinds of errors that can occur
one is a random error another one is a
systematic error
and in this table you can see that if
you have a random error
the air the qc rules that will be
violated will tend to be
the one 3s or a 1 2.5 s
or a 1 3.5 s or an r
4s so if you have the westgard rules
running
and you see the 1 3s or the r4s
most commonly implemented when those are
violated that will help you understand
looks like i've got a random there
conversely if you see errors such as the
2 2s
or the 4 1 s or the 2 out of 3 2s
or the 3 1 s or any of the mean rules
6 x 6 x 8 x 9 x 10 x
12 12x different varieties of of
x rules in different formulations of
westgard rules
when those are violated because those
are all multiple measurements on one
side of the mean they
indicate systematic error so when you
use a set of westgard rules
when one of them is violated that rule
also tells you what kind of error might
have occurred
now you will see one rule off by itself
in a completely different column the
rules i was just talking about are in a
column
titled high ped which means high
probability of error detection those
rules are good at detecting
random or systematic errors
the column to the left is high pfr which
means
this is a rule that is very good at
giving false rejections
it will go off when there's no problem
and that is the 1 2s rule the 1
2s rule is known to have a high
percentage of false rejections
something we cannot afford in this time
we have a sars kobe 2 method we can't
have
every 1 out of 10 or 1 out of 20 runs
being rejected when there's nothing
wrong with the method that creates
too many backlogs might require too much
re-testing
in a constrained environment where we
already might not have enough tests
now we have to burn two on one person
because of bad
statistical qc choices no avoid the 1 2s
rule
we said that for all the other kinds of
testing it applies double
for stars cov2 testing
once you've figured out what kind of
error might have occurred
such as a random error or a systematic
error well then you're going to want
some kind of troubleshooting flow chart
and i'm
showing you three different kinds one
for
one that helps triage between random and
systematic
one that helps focus on random errors
and one that helps troubleshoot
for systematic errors and you know for
instance
uh for random errors you might be
looking at
maybe you might be asking are multiple
tests going wrong
do we think we have clots that can be
a kind of random error in which case you
want to flush it out
another random error that you may
encounter is you start seeing bubbles in
the reagent
and that might mean you need to change
the reagent or somehow
flush out the bubbles another
cause of of random air can be reagent
stability
on the uh on the systematic front
it usually comes down to
the life span of a calibrator
or a reagent lot as these
lots come near that the end to their
expiration date they might start to
drift
and we already saw an example of that
earlier
it's happening in the real world
and in that case you know the the
solution is
if we catch a significant degradation
well that means we gotta have new
calibrators so we gotta have new
reagent lots and
you may have to create some custom
flowcharts
that take into account those general
errors that can happen in any method but
also any
you know idiosyncratic method specific
errors that could happen on your
your covid testing method
finally i suggested earlier that
we wanted to find a middle ground we
wanted to optimize our use of westgard
rules
and we do that using what we call the
westgard sigma rules
it's a more modern uh
application of the westgard rules it
takes into account the six sigma
benchmarking so you have
six sigma west guard rules you put them
together you have
westgard sigma rules and essentially if
you know the sigma then
you can figure out how how many rules
you have to use
six sigma means you might need only one
rule five sigma
three rules four sigma four rules
three sigma all the westgard rules
so if we can characterize our covid
methods on a six sigma scale we know how
many west guard rules we're going to use
and we can even figure out how often we
need to run qc
some further advice i'd like to give
not all control levels are created
equally in sars kobe 2.
the the very low or completely
negative control maybe not so important
the low
positive controls might be the most
important and you might need to
optimize your qc design around a low
positive
because that's where you're closest to
the cut off you're closest to a change
in diagnosis so you want to
focus your uh attention
and your qc around changes taking place
there
again complex westgard rules may be
overkill
for many methods if you have a good
performing method
uh i would say if you if you think you
have a good method
drop off a 10x rule or an 8x rule or
a 6x or 9x rule because that's the most
likely
uh rule that is going to be overkill and
will start causing your problems so you
might truncate an arbitrary set of
westgard rules by one just
run for the westgard rules and then if
you can figure out how to calculate
the sigma metric you might be able to
reduce it even
even further another
suggestion i'll make is that as your
kits
change as the reagent lots change as you
modify
a signal to cut off uh point
or ratio or zones you will have to
modify
the allowable total errors essentially
you will modify your performance
specifications
when you see significant changes in
reagent lot and
adjustments and signal to cut off
the standard of having to establish a
mean and standard deviation for each new
reagent lot
we do that outside of sars cov2 testing
we need to do it
inside stars cov2 testing
so in conclusion uh just because
osiris-cov2 method is semi-quantitative
does not mean
you want semi-quality control
our biggest challenge will be to
establish a critical decision level
something like a low positive and then
figuring out
a measurement uh specific sorry a
performance
specification or allowable total error
at that level
the simplest tool we can provide you is
the westgard
sigma rules and the westgard sigma
approach
and then if you want if you have the
ability
to get even more control and
a better grip around the performance of
the method
then you could go ahead and start using
something like op specs charts another
westgard tool to find tool your to
fine-tune
your qc design i also want to note
uh some recent articles on screening
assay qc
by dr paulo pereira on the westgard
website plus
a book that he has just on qualitative
testing
that it came out of this year
and then thank you thank you for
attending
uh thank you sharon for giving us a
thorough
update of the regulatory situation
thank you to technopath for supporting
this educational session and thank you
to lab roots for providing us
a valuable platform and now we'd like to
turn
to questions and answers i hope you've
been
typing some questions in while we were
talking but
if if not you now have the opportunity
to send some questions through the q
a and we will start answering them thank
you very much
thank you stan and dr ehremeyer for your
informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
for sten
what are your thoughts on using
real-time peer comparison data for test
performance for
infectious infectious disease and other
semi-quantitative tests to run
for run acceptability measurements
that's a great question i
this is a moment where having a peer
group comparison
is really important if you think about
how reagent lots are changing
they're going to change faster than
you're going to be tested on proficiency
testing or eqa
so having a peer group allows you to see
wait i see a shift in my reagent is that
happening for everybody or is it just
something i'm seeing
so that's a really important component
and
i also might refer you that there was an
earlier webinar
um lane dmic we did early into this
pandemic and wayne demick over at nrl
he has some peer group
tools that are available for stars kobe
2.
great thank you so much stan now this is
directed to both of you both stan
and dr ehrmeier is there a third party
quality control material for sars cov2
antigen tests
well sten should i start um uh this is a
a good uh question as well and you know
as far
as i know i am not
aware of one but remember
uh all this is new and so
i would imagine in the future uh
there will be what do you think sten um
yeah i have a feeling there are uh just
as i couldn't tell you
of the thousand methods that are on the
market i can't give you
details on them all i i
can't uh i can't keep track of all the
controls coming to market
i would be shocked if there isn't an
antigen control by now
um i think more more
difficult more difficult
um for the controls they probably exist
it's just how can you get them are they
on
allocation um you know it's the
logistical challenges
as with everything else in the in the
eua covid era
that might be the real challenge it's
not so much that they don't exist
it's can you get hold of them
okay thank you both for that answer
we've got another question and this is
aimed
at toward dr ermeyer
for a waived testing system could the
lab use
external controls not listed in the
manufacturer's package insert
and if so in what way should these
controls be validated
wow really
really really good first of all remember
we're talking about
waived and certainly for those
laboratories that are testing just under
clea
there's nothing that's stopping you from
that but remember
you also have always have to
follow what is in the manufacturer's
insert
and after that you can do
pretty much whatever you want to do in
terms of
additional controls now how should they
be validated uh i think initially
you're going to have to go with is in
the
product insert simply because
you know these materials that you're
using for the wave testing
i'm sure you find are rather limited so
you cannot undergo
an extensive validation prior to
implementation
but then after you use them for
a period of time you can do a
statistical analysis on this and then
decide
what uh if you want to change uh
the level of acceptability now stan i'm
sure you probably have a comment on this
so i'll pass it over to you
um well i this is a
this is a scenario where um
you know the manufacturer is going to
tell you to do something and then you're
going to use
controls on top of that um
so to me it's it's a rare scenario where
a laboratory is using a wave system
and trying to go above and beyond
control you know what the manufacturer
is saying i mean more power to you
if you do so but most of us are
if you get a wave system you're not
doing that extra level
i agree thank you so much both of you
for those answers and we've got time for
one more question
i want to remind our audience that those
questions we were unable to answer today
and those that come in during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
email address you provided at the time
of registration
our last question is for dr ehremeyer
regarding the iqcp
not applicable for euas what do you
suggest a laboratory does in regards to
reagent allocation where it's not
feasible to run qc on every run
you know uh this this whole business
about iqcp
is really a confusing uh issue
and from in my presentation i stated
uh what cms uh states and that an
iqcp is not
uh necessary because the mandate is
to follow the manufacturer's directions
now if the uh you know if the
manufacturer
has something built into
this system then that would be it
to run something less than what the
manufacturer
suggests is just not appropriate
so i would say if you're still wanting
to do something
differently then for sure
contact your accrediting
agency and get advice from them
but remember that cms says
no iqcp follow the manufacturer's
directives
thank you again stan and dr ermeyer do
you have any final comments for our
audience
well again i just want to thank everyone
for
uh joining uh thank you for the
questions there are
definitely more questions and we will be
answering them and you'll get them
at a later time thanks sharon thanks
labrutz thanks
technopath clinical diagnostics for
supporting us
and i certainly concur with everything
that sten has said
thank you well thank you and before we
go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided
at the time of registration we would
like to once again thank
uh thanks den and dr eremeier for their
time today and for their important
research
we would also like to thank labrus and
our sponsor technopath clinical
diagnostics usa
for underwriting today's educational
webcast you can view the webinar
on demand lab roots will alert you via
email when it's available for replay
that's all for now until next time
goodbye